these eight backstabbed their professor
and created their own company using his
research well that sounds pretty bad
they weren't exactly trying to screw
over their Professor they just wanted
freedom and the ability to lead their
own company little did they know that
this betrayal would end up being the
foundation of not just Silicon Valley
but modern tech as a whole why you ask
well these were the men who
commercialized semiconductor technology
or silicon Wafers hence the name Silicon
Valley also you know how there's a bunch
of debate regarding who's the better
chip maker AMD or Intel well these guys
created both in fact they also played
integral roles in the creation of Apple
Google Oracle Facebook Cisco Applied
Materials Nvidia Juniper Networks On
Microsystems Netscape and all of these
other companies as well just to name a
few but despite the Revolutionary
contribution to the Tech scene unless
you're a text caller you've probably
never even heard of them I mean have you
ever heard of Sheldon Roberts or Eugene
Kleiner or Julius blank or what about
their Professor William Shockley I'm
gonna guess probably not so here's the
insane untold story of the traitorous 8
and the creation of Silicon Valley
[Music]
taking a look back the story of Silicon
Valley can be traced back to a man named
William Bradford Shockley Jr he was born
on February 13 1910 in London but most
of his childhood would be spent in his
family's home town of Palo Alto
California Chocolate didn't have the
strongest of backgrounds but he
definitely had grit ingrained in his
blood his father worked the dangerous
job of being a mining engineer and his
mother followed in the same footsteps
fun fact his mother would have become
America's first female Deputy mining
surveyor so these guys were very much
about the no pain no gain mentality and
that they expected nothing less from
Shockley Jr in fact they would recruit
the Stanford Professor who lived nearby
to teach chocolate physics at a very
young age clearly getting Shockley
educated was a top priority for his
parents but they weren't exactly fans of
the public school system they actually
particularly hated public schools and
that this was the main reason that
chocolate was homes colder until the age
of eight this also played well with the
fact that Shockley regularly had violent
tantrums and didn't get along with other
children all that well it looks like
this was something that chocolate never
really left behind but anyway it looks
like Shockley more than fulfilled his
parents dream as he didn't just get
educated he became a genius he would
graduate from Caltech in 1932 with the
bachelors and MIT in 1936 with a PhD
after graduation he would turn around
and join the highly prestigious bellags
if you don't know about Bell Labs think
Google moonshot Factory but a hundred
years ago chocolatey stuck around here
for a couple of years until World War II
broke out at which point he became a
research director at Columbia University
his job was originally to develop radar
technology that could detect submarines
but he ended up becoming quite close to
war leaders in fact the war department
asked Shockley to predict the death toll
of a certain explosion that marked the
end of World War II anyway Shockley
would return to Bell Labs following the
war and began researching transistors
spoiler alert This research would end up
creating modern technology but it was by
no means a fast or easy process
in the early days Shockley saw nothing
but failure with this external electric
field experiments on semiconductors but
over time Shockley and his colleagues
were able to eliminate one concern after
another and they created The Junction
transistor in 1951. the creation of this
transistor was very much a team effort
between Shockley John bartine and the
Walter Breton but the media often gave
all the credit to Shockley given that he
was the leader chocolate did go out of
his way in to give credit to his
Partners whenever possible but bourdine
and Breton couldn't help but feel pretty
resentful and they would both end up
leaving in the 1950s but Shockley was
just getting started in 1956 chocolate
bardine and Breton would be awarded the
Nobel Prize for physics so clearly these
guys were no doubt of world class but
with the bardeen and Bratton gone
Shockwave needed a new team this time he
opted to recruit a bunch of PhD students
instead of already distinguished
researchers he probably thought that he
would have an easier time managing
students than peers oh how wrong he was
Shockley would have found a Shockley
semiconductor laboratory in Mountain
View California in 1956. he would go on
to recruit a bunch of PhD students and
recent grads to the company their goal
was to make it groundbreaking
discoveries regarding silicon Wafers
let's just say they definitely
accomplished this but it was by no means
smooth sailing you know how we talked
about chocolate's violent Tantrums as a
child well these characteristics were
only magnified at chocolate
semiconductor and the reason isn't
rocket science Shockley had literally
won a Nobel Prize by the age of 46 so he
no doubt felt like he was the daddy of
the semiconductor industry as a whole
and technically he wasn't wrong but that
by no means excuses his behavior
Shockley has been described as the worst
manager in the history of electronics he
was autocratic domineering erratic hard
to please and a highly egotistical just
to name a few traits but to be honest
that's not all that different from Steve
Jobs or Elon Musk or Jeff Bezos or Bill
Gates or really any well-known figure
being like this is really the exception
when it comes to people like this but
you could definitely say that chocolate
took this to another level for example
all phone calls in the company were
recorded staff weren't even allowed to
share results with each other without
shockley's permission and Shockley even
threatened to use lie detectors at one
point this lack of trust wasn't exactly
the characteristics of a great boss but
what really scored over Shockley was his
vision for the company you see eight of
shockley's best researchers felt that
the company should focus on
silicon-based semiconductors and
commercialize the idea but for some
reason chocolate didn't want to pursue
this idea this simply led to even more
disagreements and a bad blood and it
wasn't long till researchers started
resigning most of them would just go
ahead and join Laboratories and research
teams in adjacent Fields but our Traders
Aid didn't want to pursue a different
field they could see that Shockley had a
winner it just had to be executed
correctly the group described it as
solving the Shockley problem their first
instinct wasn't to leave though they
actually tried talking to the investors
of Shockley semiconductor and asked them
to reign in chocolate but they weren't
exactly on board with this idea so our
Traders Aid decided to find their own
investors in March of 1957. the man who
pulled the trigger was Eugene Kleiner
Kleiner was one of the few people that
chocolate trusted so when he requested a
few days off to visit an exhibition in
La chocolate didn't think twice but he
probably should have as Kleiner would
end up traveling to New York and they're
pitching to investors finding an
investor was actually super difficult
it's not that investors weren't
interested in the idea but they wanted
something that was closer to home trying
to manage these brainiacs in California
from New York seem like a daunting task
to say the least but they eventually
found someone who was willing to take
the plunge Sherman Fairchild Sherman
agreed to loan our age protagonists 1.3
8 million dollars or the equivalent of
14.8 million dollars today and with that
Fairchild semiconductor was established
and the eight Geniuses from chocolate
semiconductor would officially become
the traitors 8.
R8 would instantly get to work on
commercializing Silicon Wafers their
first goal was to produce silicon Wafers
for digital devices based on the
research of bell labs and chocolate I do
gotta say though they didn't rip off the
tech completely they would actually try
to improve it themselves to build an
even bigger lead they would set out on
improving the technology using three
different methods Each of which were led
by one of the Traders eight the method
that ended up coming out on top was the
one that was led by Gordon Moore if
you've ever heard of Moore's Law well
this is the guy Fairchild would go on to
implement Morris discoveries into
chocolate's research and within no time
the company was mass producing silicon
Wafers and let's just say Fairchild
destroyed the competition throughout the
early 1960s they were the Undisputed
king of semiconductors but obviously the
company didn't keep this lead as they
have since disappeared into Oblivion so
what happened well it was the greed of
Sherman Fairchild you see one of the
conditions of funding the company was
that Sherman reserved the right to buy
autistics of the partners at any time
ideally this Clause was in place so that
Sherman could easily manage Bad actors
if someone was causing issues and not
being a team player well then Sherman
could just buy them out but the problem
arose when Sherman started buying up
Partners just because he could it's no
wonder why Sherman decided to do this
from his perspective fairchilda already
had a massive lead so he no longer
needed the assistance of the trader S8
you could say that the Trader's aide got
a taste of their own medicine but not
really the problem with Sherman's theory
was that he was just straight up wrong
the reality is that a lead within this
semiconductor industry doesn't mean
anything Moore's Law suggests that the
number of transistors in a circuit
doubles every two years there's some
debate about whether this is still true
today but it was more than true back in
the 1960s in fact transistors were
doubling it every single year and the
reason Morris law states every two years
is because Gordon was trying to be
conservative so while Fair child did
have a massive lead if this left for one
year they would lose it all and that's
exactly what happened as Sherman bought
out the stakes of the traitorous agent
they would slowly leave one by one and
by the end of the 1960s they were all
gone from there their child would begin
its descent towards irrelevancy but our
eight heroes were far from being done
foreign
[Music]
men from the trade race 8 are Gordon
Moore and Robert Noyes in 1968 this Duo
would go on to found Intel you may have
heard of them ironically their biggest
competitors AMD was also founded by ex
Fairchild employees in fact it was
created by Jerry Sanders and seven other
ex-fair child employees you could say
that these were yet another traitors 8.
it doesn't stop with the just Intel and
AMD though yet another tech company
created by these eight is amelco four of
the original eight Jay last John horny
Eugene Kleiner and Sheldon Roberts
founded this company and it would
eventually become modern day Teledyne
you probably haven't heard of this
company but they're worth 20 billion
dollars some of the other members from
the original 8 ended up taking another
path Eugene Kleiner for example founded
his own VC firm with the help of Tom
Perkins and these guys would go on to
fund slash create a compact Intuit
Netscape Sun Microsystems Amazon and it
doesn't of other smaller companies in
the meantime one of our other Heroes
Victor grenick would go on to become a
professor at Stanford where he published
a textbook called an introduction to
integrated circuits this textbook would
become the basis for how circuits are
taught in schools and universities
around the world so who knows how many
Tech Geniuses this guy inspired probably
the least accomplished of the eight but
still super accomplished is Julius blank
after Fairchild he became a consultant
for startups and eventually retired in a
retirement home right across his office
at Fairchild also if you're wondering
about chocolate he never understood why
these eight left but without a strong
team he couldn't really make any
progress so he would end up as a
Stanford Professor just like his
neighbor from his childhood but while
Shockley never hit the mega jackpot
himself and though he did have some
rather odd perspectives his contribution
to the tech world is unquestionable it
was from his little lab in the 1950s
that the entirety of silicon Ali was
born and that's the story of the
traitorous 8. did you know about our
heroes or I guess anti-heroes comment
that down below also drop a like if you
want to hear more untolded Tech stories
and of course our Discord Community
suggests for the video ideas and to
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one